une autre journée de colère devant la
Cour suprême américaine
je ne peux pas croire que nous sommes
encore à nous battre contre
l'endettement étudiant l'an 7 militante
la Cour suprême vient d'invalider une
promesse phare de Joe Biden qui voulait
effacer 400 milliards de dollars en
dette étudiant aux États-Unis le
président outrepassé ses pouvoirs dit le
tribunal on adoptant un programme
coûteux sans l'autorisation explicite du
Congrès
l'échec n'est pas une option au 17
activiste qui fait monter la pression
sur Joe Biden
le président promet de trouver une autre
voie pour mener à bien son engagement
la Cour ne s'arrête pas là et s'attaque
à d'autres remparts progressistes la
Cour suprême donne raison à lorismate
une créatrice de site web qui refuse
d'en concevoir pour les mariages
homosexuels
envers la Cour suprême qui me laisse
créer selon mes valeurs le tribunal
tranche qu'elle a le droit de refuser un
contrat qui va à l'encontre de ses
convictions puisque son travail a une
valeur créative c'est une question de
liberté d'expression une décision qui
pourrait ouvrir la porte à d'autres
formes de discrimination selon les juges
dissidents c'est une prise de journée
pour la loi constitutionnelle américaine
et les membres de la communauté LGBTQ a
écrit la juge progressiste Sonia
Sotomayor
personne ne devrait être victime de
discrimination en raison de son identité
ou de l'être aimé dit la porte-parole de
la Maison Blanche la droite américaine
et galvanisée par les récentes décisions
de la Cour suprême
que Dieu bénisse la Cour suprême d'inity
Hailey aspirante à l'investiture
républicaine elle répare de nombreux
torts pendant que les juges
conservateurs continuent de creuser les
divisions dans la société américaine les
yeux se tournent vers Joe Biden qui doit
rester fidèle à ses valeurs et ses
promesses ici Louis Blouin Radio-Canada
Washington